así que vota este por ti por supuesto
hay situaciones en las que tenemos que
ayudar y lo digo con mucha sinceridad
yo nunca lloro lucila sabemos por quién
votaremos gracias por venir chicos eso
lo vamos a ver
bienvenidos a esta donde cada voto
cuenta hoy siete desconocidos deben
decidir quién se quedará con mil dólares
los jugadores tendrán cuatro rondas para
discutir después de cada ronda podrán
votar en secreto un lingote de oro
equivale a un voto al final la persona
con la pila más alta ganará el premio
esto es stacks
starts
como estaban
esperen huelen eso
taylor del dinero en el ambiente genial
ven esta
primera ronda cada jugador recibirá un
lingote de oro tendrán 6 minutos para
discutir quién creen que debería
llevarse el premio comienza el debate
listos ya
creo que sabemos que mil dólares
ayudarían a todos los que están
presentes todos tenemos gases así que si
no lo hacíamos no les mentiría si
obtengo el dinero compraré mucha hierba
porque
está buscando algo tienen métodos los
dueños ya saben esas cosas fui a la
universidad sin para escribir guiones lo
usaría para hacer mi arte de un chico
negro y gay dije quizás apoyen a los
artistas
escribo historias tristes muy tristes e
inspiradoras comparto una habitación con
mi lola que es abuela en tagalo y la
quiero mucho pero tiene la costumbre de
acaparar más y por eso quiero mudarme
porque ya está afectando mi salud mental
vaya me imagino soy de venezuela
emigramos escapando del gobierno pero mi
abuela se quedó y cada vez que tiene
problemas cuando no tiene que comer o su
casa se cae por las lluvias ella me
llama y me pide ayuda
una deuda con capital
quieren su dinero tengo que dar celos
así que tengo muchas deudas lo que es
una locura para una licenciada soy
contadora pero no puedo tener una cuenta
a mi favor porque el mundo está sin
trabajo desde casa tengo que regresar a
la oficina en una semana sólo tengo una
bicicleta y mi trabajo está a 16 km la
pasada invención abel contra un auto
además del alquiler y las necesidades
básicas de vida usaría el dinero para
mis futuras actuaciones para el trabajo
la gasolina no es barata dios en energía
tampoco es barata yo uso bicicletas
muy bien se acabó el tiempo gracias por
debatir es hora de matar
cada jugador votará por quién cree que
debería ganar pero hay una condición si
todos los jugadores votan por ellos
mismos el juego termina y nadie gana
yo entiendo muy bien su lucha también
tengo debilidad por mi abuela así que sí
i
lo siento por ellos
[Música]
dijo que el
techo de la casa de su abuela se está
cayendo en venezuela puede tener el
dinero tengo que votar por ella
[Música]
me duelen las piernas necesito un auto
para mí
[Música]
no creo que todos sean tan estúpidos
como para votar por ellos tomaré ventaja
de eso espero que esto no me afecte
[Música]
abran los ojos en
321 ahora
nadie votó por mí
así que vota este por ti por supuesto
bien comencemos con la segunda ronda
ahora las reglas cambiarán solo los
jugadores que tienen lingotes recibirán
dos más para votar pero todos los
jugadores pueden participar en la
discusión esta vez tendrán cuatro
minutos el tiempo seguirá disminuyendo
comenzamos bien tiempo
escuchen todos para que tengamos una
idea para que usarían el dinero es decir
cero facturas autos gasolina que
comprarían para divertirse que no por
una necesidad o para años a alguien no
sabemos que nadie ayuda
yo estaba como que de qué es lo que
estás hablando disculpa no habla por ti
me sorprendió que nadie quisiera jugar a
la defensiva yo quería ganar quería todo
el dinero no sé una cámara mejor quiero
abrir un canal de youtube pero
lo siento estoy emocional les juro que
tengo la peor suerte esta mañana estaba
en max porque tengo una depresión mi
compañera de piso me dijo
lo siento en su auto conduciendo y
choque con una placa de hielo y con otro
auto y ahora además de no tener auto
tengo que pagar el de mi amiga y el de
la otra persona
yo no soy así ya sabemos por quién
votaremos gracias por venir chicos no
tenemos lingotes no podemos votar
yo nunca lloro y me da vergüenza haber
llorado en frente de todos alguien más
tiene una historia mi lola ahora está
ensuciando la cama y yo la comparto con
ella es muy difícil porque quiero un
lugar agradable para quedarme y poder
concentrarme en la escuela que harían en
que lo gastarían yo creo que me iría de
vacaciones divertidas con mi novio qué
harías tú honestamente iría de compras
no les mentiré me iría de compras y la
deuda
como una fantasía
permite
en esta ronda los jugadores pueden usar
sus 5 test para votar por otro jugador e
incluso por quienes no tienen
los ven soy una buena persona
lo siento
no
quiero mucho a mi abuela
t
será una votación dividida tengo que
elegir la estrategia pero también quiero
ayudar a gloria
[Música]
sé lo difícil que es cuidar a un ser
querido que no está bien le deseo lo
mejor
ah
bien
vuelvo a votar por mí porque no quiero
perder pero también lo siento por gloria
pero puede que tenga que ser el villano
aquí votaré por mí para tener ventaja
volviste a votar por ti en de esta ronda
pero no me di los otros le di uno a otra
persona para que no pareciera sospechoso
porque estaban sospechando sobre quién
había votado por sí mismo abran los ojos
en
regresaron al juego
antes de explicar esto por favor no me
odien para la tercera ronda y votarán
por quien creen que debería perder toda
su pila tienen tres minutos listos ya
bueno esta fue mi estrategia vote para
que regresaran yo estoy tratando de ser
la madre de los tres somos un gran
equipo ahora así lo creo no dejes que
eso te convenza bueno si ustedes tienen
cuatro lingotes cada una es obvio que no
todos ganarán estoy siendo realista sólo
uno puede ganar interesante solo estoy
siendo honesto no pueden amantes no
mientes
es muy difícil no lo que me pides es de
dios le voy a dar no tengo el corazón
para pelear no puedo sabotearlas me
sentiría fatal por supuesto todos somos
seres humanos somos egoístas sólo
pensamos en nosotros pero hay
situaciones en las que tenemos que
ayudar y lo digo con sinceridad si tiene
con sinceridad investigar sobre
venezuela verás lo que está pasando
otros no pueden ganar claro solo digo
que si estamos en esta posición ahora es
por algo y siento que decir que uno de
ustedes tiene que irse solo porque no
tienen pilas es egoísta los tres no
pueden ganar
una persona sólo buscaba estrategia y
ver con quién me podía juntar en defensa
de mi torre mi pequeña torre para que no
se hagan una idea conduje hasta aquí
desde chicago en mi solar a 2008 está en
sus últimas no sé cuánto más pueda se
viste haberlo dicho desde el principio
sus historias eran tan tristes que yo
dije lo mío no es
de mentafetamina tal vez sería más fácil
no sé qué desempatarán y si luchan por
el premio estoy bromeando
[Risas]
se acabó el tiempo es hora de votar
los jugadores que tienen lingotes
votarán por quien creen que debe perder
toda su pila
cuánto tiempo tengo
voy a votar por georges porque sólo
tiene un lingote
aunque esto es un juego se trata de
personas reales con problemas reales
[Música]
acabo de dejar que el destino decida y
por destino quiero decir tin marín de do
pingüé se lo siento
[Música]
321 ahora
zach perdió su pila pero ahora tiene la
oportunidad de redistribuir su lingote
puede dárselo a quien crea que lo merece
[Música]
le dio un golpe a ed y cuando me dio su
lingote dije vaya yo voté por ti amigo
no sé ella me agrada antes comenzamos a
hablar de tonterías supongo que se
convirtió en mi amiga
stores es gracia tenemos una última y
definitiva ronda la cuarta
y
tienen dos minutos para esto y no les
diré las reglas para votar bien suerte
bueno lo siento por ustedes
no vote por ti no importa es un juego
quiero ayudar iré a llorar a mi auto
bien creo que como es la última a las
tres deberíamos hablar y dar más razones
no le es fácil preseleccionar yo en
cuanto a los recursos estudie todos los
recursos que tengo disponible y llegué a
una vivienda de emergencia en mi escuela
y así es como planeo encontrar una
vivienda y también estoy tratando de
encontrar a un psicólogo de mejor
calidad porque el que tenía era uno
gratuito y me dio un diagnóstico después
de una llamada de ocho minutos esta
semana estuve a punto de comprar un auto
uno con 160 kilómetros y lo llevé un
mecánico para examinarlo y me dijo que
estaba muy estropeado que no lo comprara
en eso me gasté 300 dólares así que
estoy mucho más endeudada que antes y no
sé si ayudaré a mi abuela pero también
tengo muchas deudas y esto me ayudara
esto me dará algo de tranquilidad para
no tener que
trabajar tan duro y poder mantenerme y
así ayudar a mi abuela entienden esta es
la regla que les oculte no les daremos
más lingotes para la votación final los
jugadores podrán mover un ingo t de
cualquier pila a otra solo los jugadores
que tienen pilas pueden votar
lo siento esto es mucho estoy como
bien tal vez no es tan malo
[Música]
y
a
[Música]
me siento muy muy muy mal pero de verdad
de verdad necesito esto
[Música]
no creo que gane pero pensé en causar
algo de caos y discordia ya veremos qué
pasa no sé bien abran los ojos en
321 ahora
muerte
quería que las cosas se pusieran
interesantes cause un poco de caos lo
hice
iremos a una ronda especial de desempate
las jugadoras que tienen las pilas más
altas tienen que luchar no físicamente
pizza y gloria tendrán 30 segundos para
exponer su caso
desde que tenía 17 años he sido
económicamente independiente trabajé
para conseguir todo lo que tengo y este
dinero me ayudaría a mudarme y a ser
capaz de tener mi propio espacio y de
esta manera encontrar el equilibrio que
necesito en mi vida
cada vez que alguien tenía algún
problema dejaba de hacer cosas para
darles dinero darles tiempo lo que sea y
durante la pandemia nadie hizo eso por
mí cualquier ayuda que pueda recibir
aunque sea solo de jubilee odio ustedes
estaría genial sí
los jugadores que tienen pilas moverán
un lingote para quien crean que debería
ganar
ánimos
ya tenemos los resultados del desempate
entre gloria y fitsa abran los ojos en
[Música]
[Risas]
felicidades min
tipsa ahí estás crea malvinas
cómo te sientes me siento muy bien y muy
mal al mismo tiempo me alegro por ella
se merece el dinero pero cualquiera
debería tener una oportunidad justa
quede como un genial soy el idiota
amargado a algunas personas no son tan
malas como parecen zach me sorprendió
aunque no gane me siento bien porque me
sorprendió me recordó que no hay que
juzgar tan rápido mi mayor lección es
que hay que ponerse a uno primero siento
que será única manera de ganar en esta
vida siendo egoísta a veces de verdad me
siento muy muy aliviada estoy muy
agradecida por la oportunidad y no
quiero arruinar lo
bien eso es todo por este episodio
muchas gracias por vernos y
lo manifesté
estén atentos al próximo episodio para
ver si alguien consigue una pila más
alta
adiós adiós